comment ça
va
tu
ilation exactement il y a combien de
temps
maintenant 3
ans même plus que ça peut-être ça faire
quasiment 5
ans on viill pas ça voit
pas
bonjour je suis Aurélien Pradier député
de la première circonscription du lot et
un des combats que j'ai mené depuis mon
arrivée à l'Assemblée nationale est
celui de l'inclusion des personnes en
situation de handicap au sein de notre
société dans sa circonscription du Lot
autour de
cor la lutte pour l'inclusion des
personnes handicapées doit être mise en
œuvre dès le plus jeune âge selon
Aurélien
Pradier et pour savoir comment le député
LR a tenu à nous montrer l'école
maternelle de Catus un modèle du
genre bonjour directeur ça va bien vous
allez bien oui ouais très bien cont de
venir voir bonjour ça va ouis bien au
milieu de la cinquantaine d'élèves
certains petits sont un peu différent
des autres ce sont des enfants autistes
une unité spécialisée a été créée pour
eux donc là tout le monde à la
récréation au même moment tout à fait
aujourd'hui vous avez combien d'enfants
dans dans l'unité 7 7 le C des char 7
j'en a se en fait on va être sur
deintervention qui va être précoce 3 6
ans pour les enfants sur
l'accompagnement qui sera intensif parce
qu'on est sur 24 heures d'accompagnement
semaine chaque temps et penser sur des
objectifs en fait bien précis la
récréation ça va être un objectif bien
précis de pouvoir travailler les
interactions avec ses paères travailler
la gestion des émotions
mais il n'existe que 2000 places d'un
tel dispositif en France quand 10 fois
plus d'enfants de 3 à 6 ans ont été
diagnostiqués
autist ça veut dire que les enfants
autistes sont pris en charge comment
majoritairement auourd' pas scolariser
ou très peu les gamins qui vont faire
une demi-journée par semaine
glorieusement quand on veut bien leur
donner une demi-journée par semaine et
le résultant ils sont à la maison en
structure en structure hors du milieu
ordinaire en fait 40 % des enfants
autistes n'ont accès à presque aucune
forme de
scolarisation pourtant les progrès
permis par ces unités sont gigantesques
prenez amine il est arrivé ici il y a 2
ans sans savoir parler et avec de gros
retard pour son
[Musique]
âge désormais il a autant de compétences
que les autres et pour cause il passe
une grande partie de son temps hors de
son unité spécialisée mais dans une
classe de grande section
classique seule différence léomara Pinto
la psychologue de l'école l'accompagne
pour l'aider à
progresser c'est bien am regarde
maintenant le petit le petit tu as écrit
l'uite c'est les mots
cochons oui c'est très bien c'est là que
tu mets ah oui oui ça il est là et tu as
déjà fait c'est parfait tu vas mettre
résultat amine va pouvoir intégrer un CP
classique l'année prochaine mais pour C
élèves autist il faut 5 adultes
supplémentaire dans l'école une prise en
charge qui coûte 25000 € par an pour
chaque enfant accueilli et qui est trop
rare c'est une question de moyen sont
des budgets qui sont assez significatifs
mais avec des rés qui sont qui sont
exceptionnel des enfants qu'on
accompagne dès le début ce sont des
problèmes qu'on a pas à gérer avec une
telle ampleur après c'est ça qui est fou
c'est qu'en fait économies de bout de
chandel qu'on fait là où on pourrait
intervenir on les reprend en pleine
figure quelques années
après mais ouvrir des classes
d'enseignement spécialisé est un vrai
parcours du
combattant leur nombre est décidé au
niveau national et les territoires se
font une concurrence accrue pour les
accueillir Aurélien Prad en sait quelque
chose il est en plein dedents pour une
école élémentaire dans son fief de la
Bastie de Mura la commune où il a grandi
une enfance bouleversée et qui explique
peut-être un peu son engagement
actuel le handicap il a frappé ma
famille et mon père quand j'étais très
jeune on a changé notre notre vie on
m'aurait dit que je m'occuperai du
handicap en faisant de la politique
j'aurais sûrement paré non parce que
c'était tellement présent dans ma vie
que j'avais peut-être pas envie d'en
faire encore davantage mais en fait vous
êtes un peu rattrapé toujours par ça et
puis et puis moi je ne crois pas qu'on
fasse de la politique par hasard oui oui
après des mois de tractation c'est son
ancienne école qui a été désigné pour
ouvrir une classe accueillant des élèves
autistes à partir de 6 ans Monsieur moi
c'est lis ang toi je t'ai reconnu cousin
toi je t'ai reconnu mais comme vous êtes
quelquesuns à avoir bien grandi ça
pousse ouais il faut pas que je passe 6
mois sans vous voir parce que ça fait
bizarre donc la salle qu'on est censé
utiliser pour accueillir les enfants
après l'avoir rénové c'est celle-ci et
donc il y a tout à faire va repeindre
adapter
remeubler donc l'avantage c'est qu'ils
seront au milieu de tout le monde il a
pas de on met pas dans dans un endroit
isolé là ils sont vraent dans la vie de
l'école mais il y a un peu de boulot il
a bien fallu toute son énergie de député
pour convaincre à la fois l'éducation
nationale mais aussi les autorités de
santé que l'équipe enseignante était ici
extrêmement motivé pour tenter
l'expérience mais à quelques mois de
l'ouverture rien n'est encore gagné donc
on a réussi à obtenir ça après des
années de bataille donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle on aura cette unité ici et
maintenant on va être sur toute la mise
en œuvre qui est là aussi compliqué
parce que comme les décisions viennent
d'endroits différents les infos viennent
d'endroit très différents donc on croise
nos informations entre ce qu'a décidé la
RS ce qu' décidé
nationale pour accueillir TR enfants
autistes à partir de janvier il va
falloir encore trouver un enseignant
spécialisé et de ce côtél c'est encore
la pénurie moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est
le recrutement l'enseignant spécialisé
parce queus il m'exliqu que ils avent
l'enseignant dès le mouvement de la
rentrée le manque de personnel un
problème crant chez les Aes ses
accompagnants élèv en situation de
handicap exerçant en milieu ordinaire
pour tous les enfants handicapés on en
compte 125000 alors que 430000 seraient
nécessairire mais impossible d'en
embaucher davantage Aurélien Pradier qui
les reçoit ce jour-là c'est bien
pourquoi bon bienvenue certaines vous
connaissez déjà le bureau l'idée c'est
qu'on parle du concret là comment la
rentrée se passe depuis depuis début
septembre dans le Lot alors moi je
travaille pour quatre enfants en même
temps avec des pathologies complètement
différentes et là il faut s'adapter hein
et les pathologies on en voit de plus en
plus d' enfants autiste dans ce pays on
en voit de plus en plus donc on il a une
reconnaissance mais c'est pas une école
inclusive parce qu'il y a pas ce qu'il
faut derrière donc c'est c'est une
aberration il y en a plein plein plein
qui disent qu' V qui tiendront pas le
rythme à ce niveaul financièrement en 24
he c'est je me cache pas c'est 800 97 €
et quelques
centimes n pas au 900 le problème moi je
pense des c'est qu'aujourd'hui n pas
statut reconnu et tant qu'elles ne
seront pas fonctionnaires d'État ça sera
le bazar elles n'ont pas de fiche de
poste elles n'ont pas de d'autres
couverture que celle qu'on connaît
c'est-à-dire que voilà enfin c'est c'est
trop précaire elles n'ont rien elles
n'ont rien et puis en plus il manque les
formations il manque
tout leputé posé une proposition de loi
pour améliorer le statut et le salaire
des
aesh et il pense avoir gain de cause
cette fois contrairement à ce qui s'est
passé lors de sa dernière
tentative en 2019 moi j'ai pas de
problème tout le monde était d'accord
pour voter le texte de François Ruffin y
compris en passant par l'Assemblée
nationale les seuls qui ont bloqué étai
ceux les élus d'Emmanuel Macron ENF
voilà c'est un élment factuel mais en
2019 le scandale politique il vientnent
là c'est que le texte n'a pas été rejeté
simplement la majorité a fait une motion
de rejet prélable pour qu'on l'examine
pas évidemment ils sont pris une volette
de bois vert aujourd'hui il y a un vote
je connais résultat parce que ceux qui
l'avaient bloqué en 2019 sont moins
nombreux voilà c'est
tout des batailles à l'Assemblée il en a
déjà à gagné notamment celle de la
déconjugalisation de l'allocation adulte
handicapé
qui a Peris au personnes de ne plus voir
le aide réduite quand es sont en couple
un enjeu car 20% des handicapés vivent
sous le seuil de
[Musique]
pauvreté autre moyen d'en finir avec la
précarité l'emploi Aurélien Pradier
connaî bien cetteate de Chor une
entreprise adaptée pour les personnes
handicapé qui donne du travail à 400
salariés c'est un atelier parmi nos 5
ateliers ça va va ouais tout va bien bon
c'est vous qui êtes à la paperasse euh
ben oui on av pour faire le pour faire
les jumis pour faire les mouillag mais
sinon je fais aussi un petit peu aussi
pler sise aussi je fais les deux faites
les deux je fais les
deux ici tout est fait pour adapter les
tâches aux possibilités des gens et les
faire travailler à leur
rythme
mais depuis quelques temps ces zates
doivent accueillir d'autres types de
public fait on a de plus en plus de
personnes par contre qui arrivent du
milieu ordinaire et qui échou Milie
ordinaire qui du coup sont réorientés
vers le milieu protégé c'est le cas de
six personnes récemment embauché ici
très révélateur selon le député du
manque de prévention au sein des
entreprises monde du travail de plus en
plus brutal pour lequel des profils plus
fr agile ont de plus en plus de mal à
résister et et souvent le milieu
ordinaire les les éjecte pour dire les
choses comme elles sont sauf que les
zates qui historiquement ont été conçus
pour des travailleurs handicapés parfois
avec des handicaps lourds des handicaps
qu'on connaissait pas forcément les
handicap psychique tel qu'on peut les
connaître aujourd'hui bien ils arrivent
dans un environnement qui n'est pas
exactement fait pour eux après il y a un
vrai débat est-ce que est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'il faut à 100 % faire évoluer le
milieu protégé pour qu'il accueille tout
ce que le monde du travail ne peut pas
accueillir ou est-ce qu'il faut pas
aussi je pense que c'est nécessaire
travailler sur le monde du travail pour
qu'il soit capable lui-même de conserver
peut-être de moins abîmer parce que
c'est aussi une
question le député du lotte a fait du
handicap son cheval de bataille parce
qu'il veut d'une droite solidaire et
sociale parfois à contrecourant du parti
ou je viens presque une fois par an oui
oui pour voir si vous avez pas
vieilli le blanc à part et les couleurs
le met à part en rouge rouge clair ou
rouge foncé le mett une corbeille à part
paril mouillage com politique quoi il
faut pas mélanger les
curur depuis la loi handicap de 2005 les
politiques en faveur de l'inclusion des
personnes handicapées se sont multiplié
pourtant les objectifs définis par le
texte sont encore loin d'être tous
atteints
[Musique]